Kaylee mcenany great to see you thank
you thank you as always
wow welcome to New York City we're back
with our Outlook wow what a round
big show tonight Tommy Lair and Jimmy
Fallon clay Travis uh great Jared Allen
dershowitz and a special report on the
Ocean Gate submarine tragically imploded
in the North Atlantic killing all five
passengers aboard uh also tonight
congresswoman Lauren bobert will join us
she today introduced articles of
impeachment against Joe Biden your
president and apparently he's in this
battle with Marjorie Taylor green maybe
I can be The Peacemaker because they
will inherit the Earth but we'll see now
we'll also hear from house ways and
means committee chairman Jason Smith
earlier today his committee released
bombshell testimony from not one but two
IRS whistleblowers now based on their
serious allegations get this pay close
attention it appears the Department of
Justice he thought it was corrupt it's
even more corrupt this is a corrupt
organization they went to Great Lengths
to protect Joe and Hunter Biden from
ever ever facing criminal charges
despite what is a mountain of damning
evidence according to these
whistleblowers the IRS recommended
felony tax charges against Hunter after
they uncovered get this
8.3 million dollars that he took in that
was mysteriously excluded from Hunter
Biden's tax returns uh now that income
came from foreign entities in Ukraine
Romania and China that's only three
countries what about Russia uh and and
Kazakhstan and Mexico and a dozen other
countries in fact Hunter reportedly
received around 6 million dollars from
China and it appears that his father was
in on it in one encrypted text message
listen to this between Hunter Biden and
a Chinese business partner this stated
July 30th 2017 Hunter was very angry
that a quote commitment from China was
not fulfilled threatening big
consequences from quote the big guy
himself his dad who was sitting right
next to him that he wasn't made whole
quote I am sitting here with my father
and would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
Hunter continued quote I will make
certain that between the man sitting
next to me and every person that he
knows and my ability to hold a grudge
that you will regret not following my
direction I am sitting here waiting for
the call with my father pops who takes
half his income the big guy Joe now with
my father now didn't Joe promise the
American people over over and over again
I never once spoke to my son about his
foreign business dealings not one time
but it appears Joe is a critical part of
that business instead of investigating
the suspicious activities well the doj
went to Great Lengths we now know to
protect Joe Biden and his son these
whistleblowers testimonies were
mind-blowing Biden appointed U.S
attorneys they blocked felony tax
charges against Hunter in Washington D.C
and in the California state of Gavin
Newsom Merrick Garland refused to
request to appoint a special counsel he
also delayed Hunter's case until his
multi uh million dollar crimes were past
the statute of limitations the doj also
stalled an investigation into possible
crimes outline in Hunter Biden's laptop
from Hell especially ones that impacted
his father the big guy and according to
whistleblower testimony Hunter's
Infamous laptop was quote verified by
the FBI in November of 2019. that's
earlier than we thought but
investigators thereafter were barred
from seeing it now assistant U.S
attorney Leslie Wolfe also discouraged
investigators from pursuing questions
related to Joe Biden now Wolff also
delayed investigators from interviewing
one of Hunter's business partners
because quote she did not want them to
ask about Joe Biden the big guy now
Federal officials also allegedly barred
investigators from searching a guest
house where Hunter Biden was living in
September of 2020 despite more than
enough probable cause that would have
warranted such a search warrant now they
had no problem raiding Mar-A-Lago but a
Biden guest house where Hunter was
living that was totally out of bounds
now the bidens were also allegedly
tipped off by the feds prior to other
possible searches and interviews now if
these allegations are true this is
public corruption on a massive scale
these are two credible IRS
whistleblowers not one two this is on
top of and separate from that 1023
allegation now Joe Biden is all smiles
Hunter Biden's feeling great take a look
Mr President
the doj has been weaponized they have
made a mockery of our justice system and
our constitutional order a Biden commits
a crime the Democrats the doj they bury
the evidence it is repulsive disgusting
but of course the doj says they have
done nothing wrong quote as both
attorney general and U.S attorney David
Weiss have said U.S attorney Weiss has
full authority over the matter including
responsibility for deciding where when
and whether to file charges as he deems
appropriate yet somehow wife's never
fire filed felony tax charges against
hunter or any of the other possible
crimes detailed in Hunter's laptop now
after a long five-year investigation
into Hunter Biden the feds come up with
what two misdemeanor tax charges for
missing an IRS deadline on just over two
hundred thousand dollars in taxes on
what three million dollars in income
over two years and a gun charge that was
deferred that means Hunter Biden will
not spend a day in jail that means the
big guy doesn't have a care in the world
as long as Merrick Garland is the AG and
Christopher Wray is running the FBI that
means that Joe Biden's Department of
Justice it is a part of the executive
branch is a disgrace our two-tiered
system of justice has never been this
egregious but the American people
thankly thankfully they are not blind to
the reality a majority of Americans see
right through this and believe that
Biden is corrupt and 62 percent believe
that the charges against Donald Trump by
Joe Biden's justice department are
politically motivated and you the
American people as per usual you are
correct hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else